why does it take 360 pages of abstruse
symbols to prove that one plus one
equals two
occam's razor says we can cut this we
can just say one plus one equals two
because every single last one of us
believes it does
so what do you make of that why is it so
complex to prove something simple like
one plus one equals two do we even need
that
and this question comes from roy dobson
so
uh
let me answer the
let me answer a different
question uh
you know so one plus one equals two so
the reference is probably to uh work of
uh russell
um
basically
if your axiom system is
very very very basic
and
and very very um
primitive in a way very very
simple-minded and you want your axiom
system to be very very very basic
then it might be that even proving one
plus one equal two would be difficult
but it will be a part of the build up
and later you will be uh
proving harder things and
but the truth is i see
okay but let me give you an another
example okay so uh you know there is the
intermediate value theorem
the intermediate value theorem says uh
that if you have a function continuous
function
so if f is continuous
and it's negative here and positive here
then at some point it crosses zero
we teach it in week seven
maybe i don't know of undergraduate
calculus maybe it's just week five or
maybe it's week nine i don't remember
okay
you can ask
this is so idiotic
right why
why does it take five or seven weeks to
prove the obvious that if you go
continuously from here to here you'll be
crossing zero
and the answer
is that when you prove the intermediate
value theorem
you are not actually proving the
intermediate value theorem
you are actually testing
your definition of continuity
you're testing
your abstract setup
you're testing your abstract setup your
your language you're testing uh
you know the the machinery of for every
epsilon there exists a delta such that
blah blah blah if you could not prove
the intermediate value
theorem you'd be rejecting the abstract
system
not the intermediate value theorem you'd
be rejecting this not that
so
the seven weeks were not about the
intermediate value theorem they were
about
this for every epsilon there exists
delta and then you can ask
what's for every epsilon there exists
delta for why do we need this well we
don't need it to prove the intermediate
value theorem the intermediate value
theorem was testing this
what do we need it for
and the answer is well there are later
things
like
uh e to the x is equal to sum of x to
the n divided by n factorial
which is this by the way looks innocent
and people think they understand it but
it's actually a miracle
and this miracle depends or well it
doesn't depend but i mean there are
maybe other ways to reach there but but
but you you will believe this miracle
miracle after you've understood this
system
so
uh so the answer is uh in a way we
didn't go from
uh
uh
here to here
to here
but more like this was known it
validated this and then
we could use it to do other things
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you